well ro let's get him to rip my drip man
because you really Wow am I owe you a
motto you're coming in full Jesse
Smollett today huh Frank and half-white
yeah bro oh don't be mad but what
happened you hurt your neck it's a big
hit you in the back with the scratchin
bro I got a new yoga instructor Wow and
what oh my god dude what happened nope
that's just me giving the full front
door I've been doing a lot of dela so I
want to see them peaches out the back
some hams out the back bro that peach
looks cobbled bro it looks like you got
like eight already kind of [ __ ] don't
be mad at the kicks either son uh you
had a pet Python as a kid huh huh you
know Python is kid no but mine's like
the time my neighbor's snake got loose
and uh and they found it years later we
could hear it at night and it was huge
always so big man who they're scary
anyway it was hard to sleep with you
when you hear snakes in the wall oh well
my shoes are made of that snakes okay oh
look at this did you start and [ __ ]
somewhere with a couple of little people
or meet us
looks like I'm talking [ __ ] to small
people yeah looks like you're stalking
[ __ ] too uh the people that performed
that song all the small things at the
MTV Music Awards about 20 years ago Wow
okay yeah looks like you went up to
Santa's elves and started [ __ ]
selling bad oil to him dude I'm to get
him to put outboard motor oil into a
[ __ ] actual vehicle or an [ __ ]
you're not feeling all black I feel you
you and I we look at you dude look at
that bro what's up I look like I'm
surfing well you look a hundred percent
straight up flex it can do you like yoga
at UH at the at a correctional is you
got there bro take forever to get there
I look like Tony Hawk's [ __ ] shitty
security like I got a foam on a
skateboard no you look like Timmy
penguin but you don't like Tony Hawk
[ __ ] troubled bird Jesus and what are
those pants made out of spray-on
licorice who did your son paint those on
you this morning
check out the peach bottom baby Levi's
game teams get games that's my [ __ ]
dick game rohauer huh that's all game
for you
that's that Dark Knight dick game let me
see what you don't [ __ ] you got hunted a
bro give me Theo let me see what deals
Rock and we get rip much oh wow look at
him really dressed up today yeah gray on
gray it's not gray
you look like Jesse SMO let's [ __ ]
event planner this isn't oh yeah creepy
dude you look like riff Raff's dumber
brother that went to home scared
first of all Jesse small its event
planner is Frederick David Douglas Duke
bro
that's who's playing is he small active
what are you doing right there man I'm
doing drugs and retching yes you don't
have to do a lot of who's like Joe Dirt
live on Broadway good finally are only
14 episodes okay let's move on you're a
handsome dude was tying my shoe that's
what I was doing you I'm not Matt the
outfit man you look like a [ __ ] gym
teacher or whatever that's your vibe you
know give up that vibe like I'm a gym
teacher and I'm just gonna coast through
this year I love those I could see that
you look like a gym teacher like a dude
who's been teaching a bunch of gyms how
to meet each other in a back alley
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]